[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to the heroes
path
our journey to uncover the different
routes the key players took during the
event known as the great calamity this
is episode 3 of a seven-part mini-series
covering this subject
if you haven't watched the first two be
sure to give them a watch too as this
part
ties into the overall arc presented in
those episodes
today i'm joined by my good friend
conrad better known as the host of the
commonwealth realm
a wonderful channel devoted to
everything nintendo and in particular
the zelda franchise
let's just say that this isn't the first
time we have worked together
as we have been creating content
together for well over a year now and
i'm happy as always to have him with me
on the channel and continue this trend
and very fitting too since he is
apparently closest to the rook in terms
of his appearance
if we are to believe this app he too
will be posting his own video about the
upcoming hyrule warriors age of calamity
and how it will be the darkest zelda
game
up until the release of the highly
anticipated breath of the wild 2.
a link to his video will be in the
description and the end card as always
but enough delay let's jump right back
into the noise
the moment the return of the fabled
calamity gannon is undeniable
derek doesn't hesitate for a moment and
commands the pilots to get to the divine
beasts
as quickly as possible and urges link to
head for hyrule castle with the strategy
now set
the group moves across the promenade
when they reach the west gate of the
lanera road
princess zelda link and obosa continue
on to kakariko village
while the rook moves over quarters shelf
and down in the la neru wetlands
interestingly enough instead of sticking
to the east side of the wetlands and
heading for zoro river in a straight
line which would be faster he slightly
moves north west and crosses right
through kapunka village
the rook small detail suggests that he
might have purposely decided to drop by
gapunga village
either to warn the villagers or to
actually take part in a small battle
at this point it would be way too early
for any guardians to have arrived here
as
link and zelda are only barely halfway
to the castle however
age of calamity shows us that guardians
weren't the extent of the hylian's
problems
as we see both monsters and guardians
taking part in the war
gopunga village might be under siege by
a horde of monsters at this point
most likely lisafos as they are native
to this region
on top of that creating a champion shows
that an evacuation line for the citizens
of kapunka
was set up from the village up
sahasrara's slope
and into kakariko village it's possible
that daruk took the lead in this
evacuation instructing the villagers on
where to go
from gaponga village the rook treks
across lineback island
over the pier that stretches across the
zoro river and up into trilby valley
as he moves further up he reaches a fork
in the road one of which leads north
east across turner trail
and towards akala citadel or north into
the moor of death mountain and towards
goran city
and subsequently varudanya just like
what was the case with urbosa's path
age of calamity might choose to alter
the backstory provided by creating a
champion and come up with a slightly
different scenario
in the book the rook moves straight up
the maw of death mountain and to his
divine beast without any detours
however in the trailer for age of
calamity we see a short scene of daruk
battling a high knocks at akala citadel
what we don't know as of right now is if
this takes part before
or during the calamity daruk is wearing
his blue champion's cloth but as some
have pointed out the cloth was received
before the champion started their
training sessions to control their
divine beasts
so there could be enough time in between
for this to happen
on the other hand we can spot a
seemingly dead guardian in the
background
which shouldn't be there before the
calamity since all the guardians were
supposedly being kept at hyrule castle
this still leaves the option open for
this taking place during the calamity
rather than before it
in this case we're going to do the same
thing we did with urbosa and sketch a
gameplay scenario to cover both
options one in which guru plays part in
the defense of the citadel
and one in which he goes straight for
his divine beast if the part where deruk
fights at the citadel turns out to take
place before the calamity you can
consider this next scenario vane and
just skip straight to the part where
daruk moves up to death mountain
it is possible that age of calamity will
see us experience the battle for akala
citadel partly through the rook's eyes
at some point during the disaster an
evacuation line for civilians
and soldiers was set up from the east
gate of castletown
all the way to the citadel if the rook
spent a decent amount of time at gaponga
village this evacuation could be well
underway by the time he reaches the
crossroads between
tourneo trail and the maw of death
mountain this could provide a motivation
for the rook to go off course for a
while
feeling pressured to keep the desperate
civilians and soldiers safe from whoever
or whatever might be in pursuit of them
he escorts the hylians to the citadel
safely and briefly helps with the
defense until the soldiers have taken
their positions and can take over the
defense from there
it's unlikely that daruk will actually
go inside the citadel but rather
fight in front of it perhaps at the
akala bridge akala span or maybe even
the parade grounds below
getting to his divine beast is still the
highest priority
and actually going inside the walls of
the citadel would make no sense
since the front gate had to have been
sealed at some point to deny access to
the incoming guardian
hordes if we are to actually experience
the later stages of the battle for akala
citadel through gameplay
this will probably be through the eyes
of a different unspecified character
or it could even be only reserved for
cutscenes
with the battle of akala citadel about
to heat up the rook moves into the moor
of death mountain and a long climb up
the mountain road towards scotland city
there's a probability that this section
could be playable linear battle up the
mountain with monsters potentially
coming in from the front and guardians
in pursuit from behind
the maw of death mountain is absolutely
littered with dead guardians
and they can even be found further up
the road with some as far as beyond the
southern mine
we know that goron city itself was
ultimately spared from any
harm and the route might have a big role
in saving his hometown
fighting off the guardians coming in
from behind him as he made his way
up when the route finally reaches goron
city all that remains is a short hike
past the goron hot springs and across
the eldin bridge
there he unites with varadania on the
side of death mountain
he takes his divine beast into firing
position when suddenly an
unexpectedly calamity ganon unleashes
strands of malice aimed towards
mechanical beasts
with impeccable aim the machine that was
meant to subdue ganon
suddenly became a death trap for the
goron champion inside the walls of the
corrupted varidani
a spectre manifests itself from
seemingly nova
fireblad ganon with nowhere left to go
and determined to retake his ancient war
machine
the rook embroils himself into a fight
to the death with ganon's malice infused
phantom
one he is destined to lose as the blight
extinguishes his light
his spirit gets sealed inside the
mechanical monster
and becomes a mere ghost in the shell of
a machine that was supposed to bring
victory the death of the goron hero is
just one more of many tragedies still
awaiting us in age of calamity but his
sacrifice is never forgotten by his
people
and offspring won't be until 100 years
from now that link with the help of his
ancestor
yunovo will grant him an opportunity to
take a sweet revenge
on the malice infused monstrosity which
ended his life
[Music]
[Music]
you